>> IT UP AND TALKING HERE A LOT
ABOUT THE WAR OVERSEAS BUT WE
ARE ALSO FIGHTING A WAR RIGHT
HERE AT HOME IN THE STREETS OF
OUR CITIES.
HERE'S THE LATEST EXAMPLE OF THE
WICKED THAT IT BATTLE BEING
WAGED.
AS SUSPECTED SERIAL KILLER HAS
BEEN ARRESTED IN CONNECTION WITH
THE HEINOUS SET OF SHOOTINGS A
TARGETED VULNERABLE HOMELESS
PEOPLE IN NEW YORK CITY AND
WASHINGTON, D.C.
THAT KILLING SPREE LEAVING TWO
DEAD, INJURING THREE OTHERS.
AND ANOTHER MAN HAS BEEN CHARGED
WITH A HATE CRIME.
LOOK AT THIS.
THEIR HORRIFIC BEATING OF AN
ASIAN WOMAN, A RACIST PUNK
STOPPING, PUNCHING THE
67-YEAR-OLD WOMAN AND HAD MORE
THAN 125 TIMES.
SUFFERED MULTIPLE CONTUSIONS,
LACERATIONS, BLEEDING OF THE
BRAIN.
ANOTHER ASIAN WOMEN VICTIMIZED
IN STABLE CONDITION AFTER THAT.
CHRIS, COMMENT ON THAT.
>> I HATED.
THIS IS WHAT WE VOTED FOR
NEW YORK.
I KNOW WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
NEW YORK NOW.
YOU HAVE A CULTURAL INSTITUTION,
THE MUSEUM OF MODERN ART, YOU
ARE A YOUNG WOMAN WORKING BEHIND
THE DESK AND SOME GUY, NORMAL
LOOKING GUY COMES, IS UPSET.
PERMIT WAS REVOKED OR WHATEVER.
HE JUMPS THE DESK TO STAB YOU YU
AND YOUR GIRLFRIEND.
THE PEOPLE -- THE PEOPLE
COMMITTING THESE CRIMES ARE
COMMITTING THEM OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
AND DON'T THINK, ALL YOU SOCIAL
JUSTICE WARRIORS, DON'T THINK
THAT YOU ARE SAVING ONE GUY
BECAUSE HE COMMITTED OR MADE ONE
MISTAKE.
THEY COMMIT MISTAKE AFTER
THEY CONTINUE ON THEIR CRIMES
FREEZE UNTIL THEY ARE STOPPED.
AND I KNOW THIS.
I KNOW IT IN MY DNA FROM HAVING
DONE THIS FOR 30 YEARS.
AND I AM NOT SURPRISED THAT THIS
GUY OR ONE OF THE ATTACKERS HAD
22 PRIOR CONVICTIONS.
IT IS OUR FAULT THAT THEY WERE
RUNNING AROUND AND VICTIMIZING
THEM.
I DON'T WANT TO TAKE ALL THE
TIME, BUT UNLESS YOU CHANGE THE
BAIL LAW IN NEW YORK STATE, AND
UNLESS WE GET RID OF THESE
PROGRESSIVE D.A.s, THEN WE
HAVE NO HOPE.
YOU JUST BETTER HOPE THAT IF YOU
GET SHOT OR STABBED THAT YOU
DON'T DIE BECAUSE JUSTICE AIN'T
COMING.
THE CALVARY AND COMING.
YOU ARE NEVER GOING TO GET ANY
TYPE OF RETRIBUTION.
>> AND OHIO YESTERDAY THE
GOVERNOR PASSED A LAW THAT
ALLOWS CONCEALED CARRY EVEN
WITHOUT A LICENSE OR ANY
TRAINING.
IS THAT A SOLUTION?
>> I GUESS.
IF THE CALVARY AND COMING, THAT
IS THE SOLUTION.
AND YOU CAN'T DISARM A PUBLIC IF
YOU HAVE NO CONSISTENT
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE OTHER PART OF THIS THAT WE
HAVE TALKED ABOUT BEFORE THAT
DRIVES ME CRAZY, THIS SUSPECT
WAS HOMELESS, PROBABLY MENTALLY
ILL.
ALL THESE PEOPLE STABBING
PEOPLE.
HOPELESS, MENTALLY ILL.
THE SERIAL KILLER CLAIMED BY HIS
DAD TO BE MENTALLY ILL.
AT A CERTAIN POINT DESPITE ALL
THE BILLIONS THAT WE SPENT ON
THE MENTALLY ILL, AND ALL GOES
INTO THE POCKETS OF THE
ADMINISTRATORS.
SOME MAY BE -- WHAT ARE WE
SUPPOSED TO DO?
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO HELP THE
MENTALLY ALL BUT WE LEAVE THEM
ON THE STREETS -- MAYBE WE TREAT
THEM LIKE CRIMINALS, REST THEM
AND PUT THEM AWAY.
BUT THAT SEEMS EVEN WORSE.
BUT WE HAVE NO CHOICE.
KEEP POINTING OUT THESE LIBERAL
LAWS AND NOTHING CHANGES.
THIS IS LIKE TALKING UP THE WAR.
WE TALK ABOUT HOW HORRIBLE
THINGS ARE BUT WE GO WHAT DO WE
DO?
WE -- IT IS GETTING WORSE.
>> SHE WAS IN TOWN OVER THE
WEEKEND WHEN SHOPPING ON
MADISON AVENUE NOTING SOME OF
THE STORES STILL CLOSE FROM THE
RIOTS.
BUT NOTICING HOW PREVALENT
HOMELESS PEOPLE ARE ON THE
PREMIER SHOPPING BOULEVARD OF
THE PREMIER CITY IN THE COUNTRY.
DOES ANYTHING SUGGEST
DYSFUNCTION MORE ELOQUENTLY THAN
THAT VISIBLE PROBLEM WHERE ALL
OF THESE PEOPLE, WHATEVER THEIR
BACKGROUND, ARE ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
>> I HOPE YOU WATCHED HER BACK
EVERY TIME SHE TURNED A CORNER
OR WALKED DOWN A BLOCK BECAUSE
IT IS SCARY IN NEW YORK CITY AND
CRIME IS RUNNING RAMPANT.
ONE ATTACK IN SEATTLE THAT BROKE
MY HEART.
A LONGTIME HEALTH CARE WORKER,
SHE WAS ON HER WAY AT A RAIL
STATION.
WAS GOING UP THE STAIRS WHEN A
CAREER CRIMINAL AND AN
UNPROVOKED ATTACK GRABBED HER 62
YEARS OLD, THROUGH THAT NURSE
DOWN THE STAIRS.
40 YEARS OLD.
CEMENT STEPS.
SHE SUFFERED A BROKEN CLAVICLE,
THREE BROKEN RIBS.
SHE WAS RUSHED TO A HOSPITAL.
THE VERY HOSPITAL WHERE SHE HAS
WORKED FOR 25 YEARS HELPING
OTHER PEOPLE THAT GIVES ME
CHILLS.
THAT IS AWFUL AND THAT IS JUST
ONE EXAMPLE OF THE MANY
UNPROVOKED ATTACKS THAT ARE
HAPPENING IN THE CITIES ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY.
>> MENTALLY ILL OR NOT, CRIME IS
A CRIME.
THAT IS WHY I THINK THE JUDGES
POINTED OUT -- WHEN YOU COMMIT A
CRIME, YOU SHOULD BE CHARGED TO
THE FULLEST EXTENT OF THE LAW.
HELD IF YOU ARE A THREAT TO
SOCIETY.
PRETRIAL.
AND THEN GIVEN THE FULL SENTENCE
IF YOU ARE CONVICTED.
>> WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING OF THE
LIBERALS WANT TO HELP US DO
ANYTHING.
YOU CAN'T LIVE IN A SOCIETY OF
HALF THE SOCIETY DOESN'T WANT TO
LIVE IN A CIVILIZATION.
WE CAN CROW ABOUT THIS ALL DAY.
WE'VE BEEN SHOWING THIS FOR TWO
AND A HALF YEARS, THIS CRIME
WAVE, AND EVERYONE IS WHAT'S
NEEDED TO BE DONE BUT NO ONE
DOES IT.
SO WE'RE SITTING HERE
COMPLAINING BE AS LIBERAL
POLITICIANS DON'T CARE.
THEY JUST DON'T CARE.
>> LOOK AT THIS.
>> AND THEY'RE GOING TO --
>> YOU WILL NOT SEE THAT ON
OTHER NETWORKS.
THIS STUFF DOESN'T EXIST.
>> BUT JEN PSAKI TALKING ABOUT
NO CONSEQUENCES TO CRIME.
>> IN CONGRESS THEY MEMORIALIZE
IT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DID.
>> THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE BUSY
ABOUT.
>> NEXT, CONVICTED HATE CRIM